I think if human flourishing is is
living well and so you know maybe a
question we've all asked is what is the
good life what does it mean to live well
and that's a question that philosophers
as well as people like you and me of
that over the centuries right
and so I Aristotle had an interesting
answer to that question Aristotle would
say that people flourish when they
exercise virtue and virtues are things
like wisdom and courage so if you think
of a virtue like courage then
flourishing it happens when you exercise
courage even in the most difficult
circumstances so it's possible to
flourish even if you are going through
something really hard and so I would say
mathematics is actually a vehicle for
helping people flourish so if you think
about what it what it means to do
mathematics you know part of what you're
trying to do in mathematics is seek
truth and in seeking truth you build in
abilities virtues of rigorous thinking
handling ideas well being intellectually
honest if you think about what it means
to play with a puzzle or work with a
math problem you're building in
perseverance which is helping you solve
the next problem even if you don't end
up solving this problem and so
mathematics I would say helps people
flourish